you don't have to love what she stood
for to agree that Margaret Thatcher
delivered on her vision privatization
trade union form the collapse of
communism similarly while Angela Merkel
didn't dream up German unification she
made it stick along with the euro and
domination but continent people say they
were affected because they were women
well that's patronizing guff and anyway
after the brexit own Universal Credit
Fiasco's we know that not all women
leaders can deliver big change
I think it's an Jian maggie's scientific
training that gave them the intellectual
discipline to oversee huge social change
and translate theory into practice yet
fewer than one in ten of our MPs and
just one cabinet minister have seen the
inside of a lab since school we should
be paying at least as much attention to
whether our leaders know their quantum
effects from their quadratic equations
as to their gender or race and the
government should offer techies the six
figures graduate salaries being paid by
law firms to newly qualified solicitors
there's a reason it's always science
officer Spock who saves the universe in
Star Trek brains let the geeks govern so
that we can all
live long and prosper so just so I
understand what you're calling for see
you specifically as saying or you're
directly correlating if someone studies
science at university then they are the
best suited to the job of an MP or a
leader no I'm saying that at the moment
we have a complete absence of people
with that kind of intellectual
discipline in our leadership you know if
you look at a cabinet we've got eight of
our cabinet ministers who did PPE one
universe politics philosophy and
economics very very good if you actually
want to just read books already like and
then we've got lawyers sorry are really
good for the pocket and Theresa May
geography terrific fight for finding a
way through a wheat field just one
person one person is not a scientific
background Liam Fox well you know we can
have our view about about that the point
is that we have the wrong mix and we
don't have people with the intellectual
discipline to deliver some of these huge
projects and that frankly that's what
ministers need they need to have at
least some familiarity particularly in
today's days of big tech and huge
engineering projects we need to have
somebody around the cabinet table who's
got some familiarity with that kind of
work yeah I think you're right with some
of what you're saying I don't disagree
you need to be there for Brian the bill
to carry out some of his work all right
and he could turn it all right but
what's the common sense common sense
common sense is in the greedy at this
mission for people and a lot of these
people have spent their whole life with
their noses in books I've never seen
outside of what's going on in the real
world and so that's that's a massive
training for me I don't personally and I
see a lot more veterans involved and we
look at Tom - Dan got Johnny Mercer and
my favorite of all time we've got us out
of the biggest crisis ever who could
that be
Winston Churchill okay Gordy's one day
of some sort okay so I'm not disagreeing
with you but I'm not going to say that
that would be the way ahead to just full
it with with brains because the brains
don't see outside the box
what I can't get is when I was at school
the boys who were good at science were
the weaklings who never got in the rugby
team and used to stand on the sidelines
with their gloves on a piece of string
from their overcoat and they hide in
backrooms and then they when they grow
up their jackets with shoulder pads on
so I don't quite see what they're
they're not normally the most
charismatic figures if you understand
science if you understand that sort of
what you've already just worked that out
they're not normally so if to
communicate you probably do need to do
PPE or you do need to do something
because if you with the exception I hear
of Merkel and the exception of Thatcher
they did politics is basically a
charisma business about charisma you've
got to love me how look how greater I
think if you're so clever and by the way
when I to criticize the boys they were
incredibly bright I can't even spell
physics let alone understanding it but I
can kind of sell myself and I don't
often come together let me get let me
advance in in response to that the names
Stephen Hawking yeah
Brian Cox Mark Zuckerberg who kicked
legislators Washington and Brussels all
around the park on television these are
great communicators David Attenborough
these are great community Berg who
couldn't reply to a common select
committee in the United Kingdom he
didn't want to making is that the idea
that scientists can't be good
communicators chemistry Imperial common
okay doesn't it doesn't stand up to the
test and by the way you know Donald
Trump is no Einstein but he's smart
enough to have a third of his cabinet
who are scientists so you're embracing
the US now Trevor feeling well I'd like
to be my bring sanity introduce T
omorrow who's one of our few senior as
an technology background here she is
firstly we need to be representative of
the country and scientists and engineers
are underrepresented right now but also
because technology is just becoming it
is already such a huge part of our
everyday lives I agree with G and I
agree with you Trevor I think that we've
talked on the show about automation and
the huge social and economic changes
facing this country
when I was a reporter at Sky News and I
interviewed government ministers about
our long-term strategy for preparing the
workforce for the fact that most of our
jobs where it exists in a few decades I
was met with completely blank faces you
know and I think that is partly because
people don't have the background that
allows them to understand it but it's
also a problem with short-term
governments that there is no incentive
to start planning for 20 years ahead and
that's not going to fly the way things
are changing but also I think that what
you're saying is actually part of a
bigger issue which is if you look at
Parliament in the 1970s for example I
think it's around 16% of MPs came from
manual labour backgrounds you know
around the third had worked in the
professions that figure is massively
tied only 3% of MPs now have a
background in manual labour but Aaron
peas aren't people who've actually
worked in the real world and that not
just in science across the board I think
we need people to represent us who
understand what our lives are like
otherwise they can't really think about
a quarter of the best British cabinet
that has ever been which is at least
post-war cabinet I think - I value
technology knowledge and I actually
think I've said on this show many times
I think that the future you need to
understand technology you really do you
need to understand what's going on new
people around you that know what you
know what's going on and where we're
heading but I also think that politics
and technology entrepreneurialism is
often quite at odds because if you if
you look at many successful technology
entrepreneurs for example you know
they're very dynamic they move very
quickly they're very agile they're very
free thinking they don't often operate
within boundaries of the way that things
couldn't exist if you then look at
Parliament and how Parliament has to
operate for various different reasons
the - and not always you know they're
not always equal or able to allow a
technology entrepreneur so I actually
think that when you talk about automated
automated there is the fourth Industrial
Revolution strategy that they're trying
to work on at the moment and when you
look on that group they are doing some
quite interesting things where I've
always felt frustrated is where
Parliament doesn't seem to call upon
experts to help them with their thinking
so we talk so much about the you know
the Northern Irish border and what can
we do and I've often thought to myself
get some fantastic
yeah get some fantastic tech
entrepreneurs around the table and say
to them right this is the problem that
we've got to resolve as successful tech
entrepreneurs what do you think that we
should do and I think that those guys
and ladies would come up with fantastic
ideas they don't need to be politicians
and you are but you're identifying one
of the biggest dangers I mean our
everyday life is now ruled by the great
tech companies that the so-called fangs
Facebook alphabet Amazon and so on these
people are really smart they are really
smart and at the moment they are
absolutely spanking the legislators in
United States in Europe and here because
they are better they understand this
stuff and our legislators don't so every
time they some piece of law comes up
these guys beat us and at the moment
they are wielding power unchecked the
only way that we're going to be able to
deal with it with that is if more of our
legislators and people who run things
are actually able to compete with these
clever blokes and on equal terms and at
that point I have to engineer us towards
a break so we can have our oranges at
halftime you're watching the pledge on
Sky News up next I'm saying the EU
should leave us Brits alone
[Music]